حان الوقت لتسمع القصه من وجهه نظرنا هكذا
تقول ذو قد ساسيكس ميغان ماركل في وثائقي
نتفليكس الجديد الذي يحمل اسمه هاري
وميغان الجزء الاول من الوثائق المثير
للجدل صدر يوم الخميس الماضي هاري وميغن
تحدثا عن بدايه علاقتهما وكيف كان من
الصعب جدا تفادي عدسات الكاميرا وتطفل
الصحافه هاري تحدث ايضا عن معاناه النساء
اللاتي يتزوجن ضمن اطار المؤسسه الملكيه
وكما جرت العاده احدث الوثائق ضجه كبيره
في وسائل الاعلام البريطانيه البعض كتب ان
الثنائي لم يضيف جديدا على المقابله التي
اجروها مع اوبرا ون فري منذ العام الماضي
[موسيقى]
قبل سنوات هاري وميغم قرروا يستقلوا
ينعزلوا عن العائله المالكه لا يعيشوا
حياه طبيعيه وحياه مثل الناس العاديين
والناس والمواطنين العاديين للمفارقه هما
اليوم الحدث والخبر سواء في بريطانيا او
خارجها فكيف نفهم نفسر الموقف الاول
الاساسي اللي هو لغز لكل الناس والمتابعين
لانه اذا كنت تحتاج الى الخصوصيه وتقابك
الملكيه السؤال هو اليوم
ميغان حصاده حوالي 100 مليون من وراء همم
باع السلسله الوثائقيه والتي عادت اليهم
بتكسب ماده من خلال قصتهم الخاصه التي
خرجوا بها امام عدسات وكاميرات الفيلم
الوثائق
اهو والسيد محمد انت خير من يحدثنا عن
ردود افعال الاعلام البريطاني كيف تناولت
هذا الموضوع
هذه هي يعني اساء البرنامج بشعبيه هري
ومكانته كان هاري ربما العضو الاكثر اا
يعني الذي يحبه الناس اكثر من اي شخص ثاني
في الاسره الملكيه والمؤسسه الحكم
البريطانيه في السابق وتحول فجاه ليكون
عنوان على صحيفه الصمت هاري يعني الناس
تهري او هريء الكريه او البغيض همم وهي في
اشاره ولعب على العناوين لانه ب 2005 في
شبابه هاري همم ذهب الى حفل الى حفل
موسيقي همم متنكره بزي همم ضابط ناسي همم
الماني وبالتالي انتقدته الصحف في حينه
ولكن ايضا قالت انه شاب همم يعني قليلا
وهكذا اما اليوم الصمت
شهور
وما يراه الراي العام البريطاني بانه يؤثر
او يؤذي الملكيه البريطانيه اليوم الى ان
يصبح ماده هاري ماده دسمه على صفحه الصن
الشعبيه وهي الصحيفه الاكثر تاثيرا في
الاوساط البريطانيه والانجليزيه وبالتالي
هذا يعتبر الضرب لشعبيته التي كانت تزيد
على شعبيات الملك تشارلز وشعبيه الامير
ويليام اخيه والذي يقال او ينقل عنه بانه
مستاء للغايه من السلسله